valerant has a secret agent also known
as agent 8 right secrecy has spawned
many theories on who they are why they
are shrouded in mystery and how they
might change the game
forever all right everyone we have our
official second merch drop it's super
cute super cozy super comfy and y'all
will look adorable wearing it so check
it out with the link in the description
below
I hope you're ready cuz here's the shirt
our boss has made us do so we can make
stupid jokes on the other ones so pick
this up if you like the color blue and
Esports check out the store Esports drop
2 available now agent 8 has been a part
of valerent lore yes there is lore since
pretty much the beginning there have
been plenty of rumors and speculation
about who this missing agent is and how
they may eventually fit into the game
there is even a Wiki page dedicated to
what we do know there is not a ton of
information but there is enough to try
and uncover the mystery now for the
uninitiated in valerant lore there is a
story a valerant in the simplest terms
there is an organization called the
valerant protocol fighting over a
resource known as radianite and there
are agents a part of that protocol you
play as those agents there's a lot more
with the radianite Omega the alpha Earth
the kingdom Corporation but don't worry
about that baby stay with me every agent
in the game is assigned a number
Brimstone is number one etc etc and
weirdly one of the easiest places to see
this are the official Spotify playlists
for each agent see how every agent has a
number by their name Brimstone is 01
Viper 02 blah blah blah Sage is 07 and
Phoenix is 09 we skip number eight
entirely isn't that strange in the
warm-up cinematic you can see Phoenix
opens Locker number nine and Locker
number eight well it scratched out but
seven remains fine in the Revelation
cinematic which shows the mirror Earth
the lockers go from 7 straight to 9 so
obviously people have been wondering who
the hell is Agent 8 and some people have
taken the question directly to Riot
themselves they since deleted Reddit AMA
answer narrative writer parm cheese said
simply that agent 8 would be revealed
quote as soon as they get back where
have they gone
away from the protocol that's the most
important thing they were involved and
now they are not this seems like an
agent that has been planned most likely
since valerent Inception the de said in
an AMA 2 years ago that even then they
had a lot of lore mapped out including
agent backstories Etc and there's even
been some very recent evidence that has
come to
light all right pause it right there
that logo of the person talking to ISO
that right there in my opinion is
probably agent 8 that hourglass symbol
the one that people received for play
testing ISO that sort of looks like an
eight I believe it is Agent 8 if this
person is agent8 them wanting to kill
members of the valerant protocol makes
sense when you consider that they might
have ended on bad terms with this Locker
being scratched out or maybe terrifying
unspeakable something went wrong terms
the other Earth just skips eight as if
eight is not to be spoken about and for
what it's worth we have not read a
single email or heard a single voice
line that refers to eight agent 8 might
not be too happy about how things ended
and is coming for Revenge my theory
dremal please is that agent 8 is omen or
a version of omen we know that Omen was
ripped apart and killed in some way
probably during the first light event
where Radiance became Radiance he exists
as some sort of sort of phantom he's not
even a normal radiant like others with
Fade's research putting an asterisk by
him perhaps Omen being ripped apart
means he can exist in multiple places at
once split H they don't know the meaning
of that word to be clear this is
different than Omega and Alpha Earth
what I'm talking about is one Earth
where multiple Omens exist you know from
the creative director that Omen has a
central place in the core conflict and
origin story of the valerant protocol
itself something clearly happened
between agent 8 and the protocol and
Omen is Central to the core conflict of
the valerant protocol most importantly
manen's timeline can work with this Omen
was the third agent recruited into the
protocol and technically with Brimstone
and Viper being there before him
something could have happened before the
omen we play as was recruited in my head
agent 8/ that version of omen joins the
protocol something happens he leaves
then our version of omen joins the
protocol but why wouldn't our Omen flag
this well the omen we play as currently
doesn't know a lot about his past he has
also gone under via various aliases this
could mean he just exists as different
people like JN is different from Fred
not just another name another thing
about his past I think is important is
that Omen I believe was some sort of
scientist considering how close he is to
Viper and his links to Kingdom in the
iso narrative trailer where that
hourglass is ISO is killing people
related to the Kingdom's project land PA
then he's given the target of omen who
is most likely an ex-employee of Kingdom
this email shows that Omen recognized
that Hour Glass symbol about a month
before iso's release during
investigations into iso's recent hit job
and that he wants to know about that
past I believe he recognizes The
Hourglass because it is him and ISO
cryptically hints at Omen having taken
kill contracts before something iso's
hourglass employer might know something
intimately about Omen they they say that
once you took a contract their death was
inescapable anyway I'm glad we're
friends I also think certain voice lines
can help illustrate him when before the
match starts who will they cry for once
they know they're going to die to an
Allied Harbor your combat Precision
Harbor I swear I've seen it before a
past life maybe to an enemy Omen I'll
kill that Omen I'll take his memories I
will remember to an Allied Viper someone
we know he has a relationship with I
need your secrets agent 8 is a version
of Omen but Liz it can't be agent8 we
see from the Spotify art that he's agent
three we do the omen we play as is I'm
talking about the other Omen the agent 8
version of omen maybe that version of
The Omen has the memories our version of
The Omen is looking for as to why yeah I
have no clue uh maybe Asian 8 wants to
punish Omen for something he's done
maybe Asian 8 wants to be the only Omen
I don't know we've all been looking for
a new agent to be agent 8 but he's
literally been in front of us the entire
time time in a sense and who knows maybe
I am completely off base maybe the
narrative team slack a group chat is
going off right now because they're all
laughing about how stupid I am but I
don't think anyone can blame me for
being a fan of the game and playing
around in this world that's what this is
just me being a fan but if and when I am
right I will not say I told you
so not for a little while at least um I
would like to shout out Gio who stopped
me from using theoretical physics
incorrectly I was going to use
superposition as a way to like validate
how Omen can exist in two places at once
but Gio damned me and was like you have
fundamentally misunderstood what
superposition is